new reports suggest
prince harry and his wife meghan markle
are looking to extend
their royal exit deal which comes up for
review next year
their current arrangement saw them step
back as senior royals in march and move
to california
the pandemic forced the entire royal
family to remain apart this christmas
queen elizabeth spent the holiday in
windsor for the first time in 32 years
where she praised the spirit of those
challenged by the coronavirus
charlie dagenha reports from london
in the darkest of times this year's
queen's christmas speech marks
celebration
tinged with sadness some mourning the
loss of those dear to them
and others missing friends and family
members
distance for safety when all they'd
really want for christmas
is a simple hug or a squeeze of the hand
no hug no squeeze of the hand for the
queen this year
like many a great grandmother her
majesty has had to forgo annual festive
family gatherings
aside from a socially distanced carol
service on the grounds of windsor castle
earlier this month the 94 year old
monarch and her 99 year old husband
phillip
are spending a quiet christmas alone at
the castle
last year the queen described 2019 as
quite bumpy
she had no idea what a tumultuous 2020
was about to bring
before kovid came that january bombshell
that shook the monarchy to its core
prince harry and megan stepping back
from royal duties
and leaving the country particularly
this year
prince harry's absence has been felt
says royal correspondent roya nica
i think um people miss him and people
feel sad that you know he wasn't here
with the rest of the royal family during
corona virus but at the same time he's
got that freedom that he
you know he and megan so desperately
wanted the couple quickly dived into
charity work focusing on those
impacted by the virus a scourge that
respected
no royal exemption prince charles tested
positive in march prince william later
admitted he caught it at around the same
time
the queen would have been extremely
worried that but you know her next two
direct heirs were both
stricken down with covid it didn't stop
william and kate from joining the battle
against the disease
where they could even taking a royal
train tour to support health care
workers
even the queen jumped in on zoom calls
to health care staff i've been able to
join you today
having harry around would have boosted
morale his absence felt most profoundly
during remembrance day
the former soldier had wanted to take
part but was left out
and the rest of the royals are said to
be unhappy about the lucrative deals he
and megan have struck
with netflix in an upcoming podcast on
spotify
for now there are more pressing matters
than family feud
and the queen's speech ended 2020 with a
message of hope
let the light of christmas the spirit of
selflessness
love and above all hope guide us
in the times ahead something
the entire world needs now more than
ever
for cbs this morning charlie dagetta
london
long live the queen she looks great i
mean doesn't she 94 and her husband's
99. they yeah they are still you know
doing what they do exactly just like we
are doing what
we do it's amazing to the amount of hope
you get from hearing the words from the
queen
absolutely people really look forward to
hearing from her in so many instances